there are new developments this morning  in the case of a missing Texas mother  and her infant daughter last night  police raided a home outside Houston the  Medical Examiner's Office says that a  body has been taken from the building  but it will not be identified until an  autopsy is done later today it is not  clear if it is a missing woman that  would be 33 year old Heidi Broussard a  one month old baby was found alive at  the home and taken to a hospital  authorities have not released the  identity of the child either Broussard  and her daughter Margot disappeared last  week in Austin after she dropped her son  off at elementary school police have  reportedly taken several people into  custody in connection with this case  you